[Música]
a
escala en parís aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 hoy les hablamos de un sector
económico muy importante para varios
países latinoamericanos se trata del
cacao y lo hacemos a partir de un
proyecto pilotado por una empresa
francesa en perú ecuador y colombia se
puede producir cacao es sin deforestar y
que además sea sostenible y sobre todo
viable
vamos a intentar responder a esta
ecuación con dos de las personas
implicadas en este proyecto sebastián
balmis de la empresa francesa a cao cao
bienvenido muchos besos buenos días y
también está con nosotros ernesto parra
y guerra de la cooperativa culpa de
loros en perú muchísimas gracias por
estar en nuestros estudios bueno bueno
sebastián balmis cauca es una empresa
familiar pionera y especialista en el
chocolate bio y ético desde hace casi 30
años
lleva mucho tiempo trabajando en américa
latina y con este proyecto que tiene una
financiación pública y también privada
se van vertir casi 9 millones de euros
que se va a hacer exactamente bueno este
proyecto es un proyecto un poco pionero
porque no solo tiene la ambición de
poder dar herramientas a las
cooperativas para comprobar que el cacao
es de cero deforestación sino también
pretende participar en la regeneración
de los x ecosistemas en américa latina y
más también en la parte amazónica que es
una parte que sabemos todos muy
degradadas uno de los países en los que
se va a invertir es perú que es uno de
los principales productores mundiales de
cacao bio y ético ernesto parra y guerra
usted es de la cooperativa culpa de
loros en perú presente no es un poco su
cooperativa bueno nuestra cooperativa
está ubicada en la amazonía peruana no
agrupa a 515 pequeños productores todos
dedicados a la producción de cacao a la
cultivo y producción de cacao no quienes
han establecido una alianza estratégica
con caucano una alianza de largo plazo
con responsabilidad social y ambiental
que quiere decir exactamente cacao bio
sostenible ético que quiere decir bueno
el cacao vio es un nuevo modo de
producción que básicamente
impide el uso de productos químicos
pero no para nosotros ser kaká obvio es
un modo de producción y tiene que ir con
el tema del ético el productor tiene que
tener un ingreso digno de su de los
frutos de su trabajo es por eso que
tenemos el 100 por ciento de nuestro
cacao que es bio y comercio justo el
comercio justo también abarca otros
temas que son por ejemplo el tema del
control de la deforestación que no haya
deforestación en el cultivo del cacao
vio y cuál es el diagnóstico que hace
del sector del cacao en su zona nuestro
bueno nosotros estamos trabajando para
justamente para desarrollar una cadena
de valor sostenible que nos permita
enfrentar la diferente problemática
que predominen el país por ejemplo la
baja productividad
mejorar la calidad que son de las dos
principales actividades y producir en
forma amigable con el medio ambiente
sebastià
de la empresa a cabo cada uno de los
retos lo estábamos hablando es el tema
de parar la deforestación también
recuperar los suelos que están muy
deteriorados como lo van a hacer bueno
en los suelos degradados sobre todo en
la amazonía son suelos que han sido
degradados por el cultivo de coca entre
otros también por la ganadería extensiva
y hay que primero hablar de la acidez de
estos suelos trabajar sobre la acidez
para que el ph se suba y después hacer
una serie de intervenciones a través de
insumos orgánicos al suelo para que
recupera su fertilidad
es importante plantar otro tipo de
cultivos no aparte del cacao en las
plantaciones de cacao obviamente es
importante el tema del agua forestería
el 100% de las parcelas dónde vamos a
intervenir en el marco de este proyecto
van a ser sistemas agroforestales donde
a partir del cacao se van a instalar
otros árboles de especies nativas que
puedan también participar en el
mantenimiento de la fertilidad de los
suelos entonces es todo un sistema
integrado ernesto este tabla de la
productividad que es baja como se va a
mejorar esta productividad bueno estamos
haciendo una serie de aplicaciones
tecnológicas no para mejorar tanto en el
aspecto varietal en el manejo de los
suelos el abonamiento no y
principalmente la calidad actualmente
estamos en promedio de 800 kilos y la
idea es duplicar esta producción en
lapso de que dure este proyecto del fefe
proyecto de cuatro años sin consigna me
equivoco en uno de los objetivos también
es sustituir los cultivos de coca por
los de cacao cuánta superficie hay
respectivamente de camino mira perú
tubo
una época donde se
muchos de los suelos fueron deforestados
a consecuencia de el cultivo de coca
llegamos a tener más de 200 mil
hectáreas actualmente estamos por las 50
mil hectáreas no de coca y esto ha hecho
que queden muchos es es migratoria la
coca o sea hoy día cultivan acá tienen
un poco la sustitución mañana siguen
talando los bosques siguen deforestando
robos que con este proyecto la idea de
recuperar esos suelos que quedaron
degradados no mediante tecnologías
adaptadas a las condiciones del sol y
volverlas a hacer productivos estos
suelos que quedaron improductivos
volverlos a ser productivos ya sea para
instalar cacao bajo sistemas
agroforestales o bajo reforestación de
esa manera ya no presionamos al bosque
le quería preguntar qué bueno
la coca es mucho más rentable que el
cacao tendrá que hacerse atractivo el
cacao de qué manera y claro mira en el
caso de la coca estamos comparando un
cultivo legal que es el cacao frente a
un cultivo ilegal que es la coca no en
mi país es ilegal la coca porque va más
articulada a la droga la mayor parte
lógicamente no va a haber una
comparación de la legalidad contra el
gas pero estamos tratando de darle
seguridad osea el narcotráfico la coca
definitivamente genera conclusión social
inseguridad para la población entonces
la población quiere vivir bien y mejores
condiciones de vida y es lo que tratamos
de buscar con el cacao es una
alternativa es una alternativa muchos de
nuestros productores han sido cocaleros
y actualmente ya están en la legalidad
cultivando cacao y cuando dicen muchos
de los 500 x por lo menos el 80% parece
una zona donde ha estado muy posicionado
el narcotráfico y la coca
a nivel de importaciones del cacao
a la unión europea que tan importante es
el cacao peruano bueno así perú ha sido
uno de los dos primeros países
productores de cacao orgánico
hasta el 2016
y en los últimos años ha bajado bastante
la importancia en la en la unión europea
más o menos el perú hace el 15 por
ciento del cacao orgánico importado en
la unión europea y ha bajado la
importancia de las importaciones porque
han subido a otros países africanos que
producen que a cabo orgánico que no
tienen las mismas condiciones de
sostenibilidad y eso es una preocupación
para todo el sector cacaotero orgánico
justamente hay países exportadores en
áfrica de cacao muy importantes para
francia por ejemplo como costa de marfil
o como como ghana en esos países se
produce cacao orgánico
muy poco en ghana hay algunas
cooperativas que sé que recién se han se
han metido en el cacao orgánico si puedo
hablar así pero de todas maneras estos
dos países que son los principales
productores de cacao a nivel mundial
todavía no tienen una importancia a
nivel del sector del cacao orgánico
entonces es por ahí donde se puede meter
y crecer más el cacao latinoamericano
bueno si yo creo que hay una oportunidad
de y sobre todo porque el cadena en la
américa latina hay posibilidad como con
este proyecto del fondo francés apoyado
por el fondo francés para el medio
ambiente de probar que el cacao orgánico
puede ser también un cacao sostenible y
tener ambas cosas para nosotros es algo
muy importante no solo ofrecer al
consumidor un chocolate orgánico sino un
chocolate orgánico sostenible cero
deforestación que participa en la
regeneración de los ecosistemas es una
ambición que todos tenemos
el hecho de que en este proyecto haya
financiación pública esto marca una
voluntad del gobierno francés en ir
hacia
ese lado del cacao orgánico si
obviamente hay una voluntad muy fuerte
por parte del gobierno francés de
controlar la deforestación importada o
sea francia a través de la importación
de sus productos de materia prima como
soya como el cacao como el café también
es fuente de deforestación e
indirectamente entonces el gobierno
francés estableció la estrategia
nacional contra la deforestación
importada donde a nosotros el sector
privado nos piden el apoyo para poder
controlar que los productos que
importamos no sean fuentes de
deforestación durante la pandemia hay
muchas materias primas que han subido de
precio
pero en el caso del cacao no ha sido
tanto la subida subió un poquitito pero
no digamos que no ha disfrutado de según
de los precios a qué se debe el mercado
del cacao es un mercado muy complicado
porque hay especulación hay grandes
productores como costa de marfil y ghana
y basta que estos dos países tengan una
buena cosecha y los precios siguen
bajando en el nivel mundial pero también
creo que se debe también a una bajada de
la demanda durante estos estos tiempos
de confinamiento no él le quería
preguntar a ernesto qué impacto ha
tenido en los agricultores en perú la
pandemia al bajar la demanda y que los
precios bueno qué impacto ha tenido se
ha sentido claro que sí se ha sentido
porque hay que tener en cuenta que la
pandemia en perú
tuvo casi 67 meses de cuarentena esto
obligó que los agricultores muchos de
ellos no puedan asistir a sus
plantaciones no eres cuidaron y se ha
traducido el impacto directo ha sido una
menor producción este año el año pasado
fue los seis meses
inmovilización entonces el hecho que no
se haya atendido debidamente a las
plantaciones porque no hubo
fertilizantes no hubo insumos para
aplicar han hecho que la producción de
este año se haya visto reducida no y eso
afecta directamente a la economía ahora
estamos con estos programas tratando de
recuperar eso para volver a los niveles
de productividad e incrementar la
producción de la perspectiva buena si la
perspectiva es buena porque
definitivamente estamos trabajando en un
sistema
diferenciado de calidad nuevo justamente
con está boca y que ve el aspecto
nosotros producimos el 100% del cacao
orgánico el 100% de comercio justo y
también cuidamos en forma amigable con
el medio ambiente cuidando el medio
ambiente bueno pues muchísimas gracias
ernesto parra higuera y sebastián balmis
por haber venido hasta nuestros estudios
y les deseamos muchísima suerte con este
proyecto de cuatro años
y muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir por internet en rf y
mundo.com france24 puntocom hasta pronto
amigos
[Música]